Paparazzi are one of the most feared by-products of pop culture, wouldn't you agree?
They tirelessly hunt celebrities, public figures and their families for the opportunity to photograph them in candid moments.
At the most basic level, paparazzi hang out on the streets and in public places...
...waiting for an opportunity to photograph a star.
But if you were a member of the paparazzi who wants to make a lot of money,...
...would you wait for hours just to get a picture?
This method is far too inefficient.
Paparazzi must make sure they are in the right place at the right time to get the shot.
Paparazzi work a lot like private detectives.
Each paparazzo has a network of informers to track celebrity targets.
These informers can be people who work in businesses frequented by celebrities,...
...such as restaurants, shops or salons.
The paparazzi often pay for this information.
In many cases, people who work for the star might be bribed to reveal the whereabouts of their employer.